[Music]
hi everybody good afternoon I'm Ken
Goldberg and here with me is Otto Bailey
and both of us are from the engineering
team at Google working on kubernetes
project and Google container engine we
are very happy to be here and today
we'll be talking and how to run your
production work workloads in containers
so containers containers is taken off
because of the benefits in develop board
activity the ability to start from
development environment and take the
same image to production can be a
game-changer right the ability to push
changes quickly and as many as you want
in a day can change everything and you
can really respond to business demand we
have an example from one of our
customers one of our Google container
engine customers but porch for example
and they are able to deploy from commits
to production in less than 10 minutes
they are doing it between 30 to 50 times
a day
I'm sure many of you already know that
and find that very appealing we in
Google know it for a very long time
we've been using containers for over 12
years now everything you know right if
it's self or Maps even Google cloud
platform our VMs running containers we
believe that running in containers is
the best experience both for developers
but also from operational perspective
using containers and container
orchestration we were able to grow our
fleet ten times faster than growing our
operations team now with kubernetes we
would like to include a container engine
we would like to give a google-like
experience for all of our cloud users so
what does it mean running at scale in
production right it's very different
than before how do you adjust the
quality of service to different type of
rapid application that have different
requirements how do you make sure that
every service or application
doesn't hurt other applications and
vice-versa if you really want to grow
your fleet much faster than your ops
team you need to automatically monitor
and remediate applications and machines
that are failing production changes
everything and there is another truth
that is different than the way we at
Google run you are not running in one
place I'm sure all of us would like to
have start from scratch every time we
need to choose a different platform
right stop everything and we are
starting to write a whole new code it
doesn't work like that
most production workloads have some
dependencies in existing services some
of them running on-premise in cloud
multiple cloud this means that you need
a stack that is can support you running
your containers everywhere you want we
believe you need to have the freedom to
choose based on the merit of the
underlying cloud well you want to run
your applications and we want to meet
you where you are meaning that if you
are now running on premise we want to
make sure that we are able to support
you in your journey to the cloud so a
good place to start is with kubernetes
kubernetes is an open source project a
container centric infrastructure founded
by Google at 2014 it is based on all of
our years of experience running
containers when we started with Google
cloud platform we thought to ourselves
should we provide something similar to
what we have internally to run our own
content containers to all users the
obvious answer was yes but the team
insisted it would be open source you can
imagine it was a high hard pitch to make
to take something that differentiated us
until that day and make it open source
available to everybody so why open
source first of all as developers we all
prefer open source and we like the
credibility knowing what inside how the
looks like knowing the developers having
visibility to the roadmap it also
provides us flexibility so if you would
like to change things that will meet our
need we are able to do that we can
integrate different type of tools and
for us as an engineering team we needed
that immediate feedback loop so we knew
how we are running production and we
knew how we are running Google
applications but we didn't know much
about how everybody else are doing that
and that was really important so by
building a community around our
open-source project we were able to get
feedback from partners customers and
just individual contributors and we've
taken it seriously and we've donated
kubernetes to the cloud native compute
foundation and we are also building
programs to help users make informed
decisions of which people they with whom
they should partner and where they
should put their workloads managing a
community takes a lot of effort and we
invest a lot in that so as much as we
invest in the technology we also invest
in helping partners and users wherever
they are use and leverage kubernetes
and I think we're doing a good job at
that
looking at the kubernetes community you
can see a lot of names and some of them
are speaking in this in this conference
and like Sam from box and what I like
about this community that not only
people are adopting both contributors
both vendors and users are contributing
back so if kubernetes is so amazing it's
an open source technology and everybody
can use it then why do you need Google
container engine so first of all yes it
is pure kubernetes and we are very proud
of that kubernetes is a very good tool
to automate the deployment and
scheduling and management of your
containerized applications on top of
that we are bringing our own experience
of your experience to manage your
cluster and we do all of that on top of
Google cloud platform with the best
Network persistent disk amazing
performance and such features
on Google cloud platform this provides
for you the best platform to manage your
applications instead of focusing on the
Machine and the infrastructure and of
course running in production means
worldwide at scale you can see this is
our current regions and of course the
future region so we keep expanding the
reach of Google cloud platform so how
can I convince you that this is ready
and the technology is ready to run your
production workloads I think the best
way to do it is just to use by real
customer examples and I antic was a big
story for us very exciting last year
they chose Google container engine for
its ability to orchestrate their
containers cluster at planetary scale
what was interesting about it when they
thought about planetary scale when they
planned everything they missed what
actually planetary scale is and we can
see what they thought will be the target
terrific what they planned for right so
they played five times worse than that
and then we can see what was the actual
traffic and for us it was also amazing
because something that you get when you
are a Google container engine user you
get us as part of your team right and I
think this is one of the the biggest
value when you are working on Google
cloud platform you get Google as your
SME SME stands for site availability
engineers today when we manage our
production systems we have dedicated
teams that they are responsible for
managing those production application
for Google and for our customers and
this is not about monitoring and
recovering your system
it's about continuously improving the
production creating more tools more
monitoring solution more automation to
make sure that everything is working
better all the time and when you are a
Google container engine user you benefit
from that so going back to the Niantic
story when they saw the traffic is much
better than what they expected we just
gather the team together right and we
had people from support from Niantic of
course
oh sorry and engineering team walking
together and making sure that players
can continue and play and find pokemons
so what do you get when you start a
cluster on Google container engine the
first thing we'll do so it takes about
on every three minutes and we will
provision your cluster and you will get
a control plan which we will manage for
you on your behalf and from a user
perspective you get a black box API
endpoint and we take control of all of
that but the main benefit is not about
the provisioning of the cluster but the
way that we manage everything for you so
we make sure the control plane is
up-to-date and we upgrade to the latest
kubernetes version we monitor it and we
make sure it's available we make sure we
have backups we make sure backups are
working right now that's something
something that sometimes we forget to do
and we also provision your VMs but when
we do that we'd not just take this
standard kubernetes version but we also
add some add-ons that are required to
run production workloads
if for example you need an l7 load
balancer or fluency for monitoring and
your dashboard we make sure that
everything is available and you can
immediately start deploying your
application instead of worrying for
cluster configuration I'm also happy to
announce that we just expanded our
responsibility and now we are not just
responsible for your control plane we
also do VM auto repair and auto upgrade
this means that we update kubernetes to
the latest version we monitor and
automate automatic repair it's now
available on beta and I encourage you
all to opt in to those features this
means that you get all the innovation
coming from kubernetes which is its new
features of our security fixes all in a
reliable manner now let me hand over to
Robert and he will talk about auto
scaling thanks Anne so one common
problem that application developers face
is how to handle traffic fluctuation
some applications have a sort of
predictable diurnal cycle of traffic
while other applications such as the one
by group I have large spikes during
holiday seasons when you might see a lot
of people purchasing on Black Friday or
leading up to Christmas as an
application developer you should not
need to worry about constantly tuning
your application Google container engine
can take care of that and scale the
number of VMs in your cluster and the
number of paws that are serving your
application so first a bit of background
I just mentioned pods what is a pod you
know some of you are probably very
familiar Nettie's and for others this
may be something new for you pod is a
small group of containers it's not a
one-to-one mapping with containers it's
one or more containers and this is
actually a very important distinction
because there a lot of times when you
want to build an application where two
things need to work very closely
together pod is also the atomic unit of
scheduling when you want to schedule
your application to run in your cluster
it gets scheduled with pods being
co-located pods share an IP address they
share a local disk they share local IPC
and so a good example of this is if you
wanted to launch a simple web server you
might have a custom application that
knows how to pull your website content
from github or from a cloud cloud
storage bucket or from a local on-prem
version control system and you can pair
that with sort of an off-the-shelf
generic web server like Apache or nginx
by putting these two containers together
you are then able to deploy them as a
single unit where the the data puller
can write to the local disk and the web
server can serve off the local disk the
great thing about this is that it
decouples the application development
lifecycle for the two pieces of code you
can push new versions of the web server
if there's a security fix without having
to rebuild your application and vice
versa you can update your application
without having to rebuild the web server
so now imagine you're running your small
website and it starts to get popular so
you could quite easily with kubernetes
scale the number of replicas or rep
number of copies of your website that
are running you know you could start out
with one go to to go to four and easily
handle the traffic load but you probably
don't want to spend all of your time
constantly changing the number of
replicas of your website that are
running that sounds kind of boring you
want to spend your time building new
websites so what you can do is you can
turn on horizontal pod auto scaling
which will monitor the incoming request
load and the utilization of your pods
and automatically scale the number of
pods
for you it'll actually also scale down
if the traffic to your website goes down
as well so you're not actually using
extra resources so this is great so the
number of pods keeps increasing but now
let's say your website gets really
popular and the number of VMs that you
have in your cluster is no longer
sufficient to run all of the replicas
you need for your site you can also
enable a cluster autoscaler and a
cluster autoscaler we'll look at the
unschedulable pods that you've requested
you or automation has requested to run
your cluster and will provision new VMs
for you to allow those pods to run and
it's actually smart enough if you have a
cluster with different types types and
shapes of VMs to provision the right
type of VM for your pod to run because
it runs a simulation of if I add a new
machine type will the pod actually run
and doesn't add VMs needlessly when it
won't actually help you scale your
cluster up like horizontal auto scaling
it will scale their cluster down when
the extra VMs are no longer needed so if
you have a big traffic spike say for the
holidays and then traffic goes back to
sort of a normal level after the holiday
event is over you don't have to go and
deprovision VMs to save yourself money
the cluster autoscaler will do that for
you automatically one of the great
things about working on both Google
container engine and kubernetes is that
we often find cases where we can solve a
problem for our Google container engine
users and also for the community at
large the cluster autoscaler is a great
example of this because we recognized
that this was a problem that we had for
our paying to Google container engine
users but it was also a problem for
anyone who wants to run kubernetes so in
this case what we did is instead of
writing a proprietary cluster autoscaler
that would only work with Google
container engine we actually wrote the
cluster autoscaler as a pod that you can
run in any kubernetes deployment so it
runs just like any other pod and it
talks to the kubernetes api to figure
out when it should scale up and our
implementation then uses GC ease api is
to actually scale up your cluster but
the core logic is reusable and you could
plug it into any other system to scale
the cluster elsewhere and we think that
this is a great model for how we can
enable enable people to run on ghovat in
our engine but feel like they have the
ability to run their cluster anywhere
else as well
so running kubernetes in production
often means you have multiple teams that
needs different levels of access to your
cluster it also means running
development testing staging environments
so you can validate your code changes
before you push them to production and
in Google container engine you can
leverage the power of Google I am and
kubernetes namespaces to make sure that
the right people have the right access
to your cluster so kubernetes namespaces
divide your cluster up into logical
subdomains and each of these logical
subdomains has different levels of
access control has its own DNS hierarchy
so you can easily segregate services and
you can use namespaces for whatever
you'd like
you can create a namespace for every
user in your department you can create a
namespace for every Apps that you deploy
and you can use namespaces for different
environments so you can have a testing
namespace and a staging namespace
they're quite flexible and it allows you
to easily segregate different parts of
your application one thing that we do
recommend is using a separate cluster
for your production instances because
although namespaces are great logical
boundary they are not a very firm
boundary in terms of isolation either
for security or for inter pod
utilization and with kubernetes 11.6
coming out soon you can use role-based
access controls to bind iam roles to
permissions inside of a namespace which
allows you to create very fine-grained
controls of who can access resources
within different namespaces in a single
cluster so Google were really proud of
the load balancing product so we offer
as part of the cloud platform our load
balancing is built on the same front end
imp front-end serving infrastructure
that powers services with billions of
users like Google search Google Maps
Gmail and YouTube with Google container
engine your application can also take
advantage of these amazing capabilities
just like Niantic did when they were
building pokemon go Google Taner engine
offers two levels of load balancing the
first is level for load balancing level
for load balancing is appropriate if you
need to terminate TCP connections or if
you need to handle raw UDP packets level
for load balancing sends your traffic to
what we call a service service in
kubernetes is a group of pods that
provide a stable IP and one thing you'll
know if you if you want to run
containers they can get rescheduled is
that containers can move around inside
your cluster and so by using a service
you know that your traffic will always
get to your pas
even if those pods have been relocated
on to new VMs external services are then
exposed with an IP address by default
services are internal and not exposed to
the Internet but it's quite easy to
expose them and on Google container
engine this is done with a cloud Network
load balancer the other type of service
that we use is called an l7 service so
many applications that are built today
are built on top of sort of the web
foundational standards of HTTP and HTTPS
we have an object in kubernetes called
an ingress object that makes it very
easy for you to configure this l7 load
balancer and the power of the l7 load
balancer is it with a single exposed IP
address and port or domain name you can
easily map traffic to multiple services
in your cluster so you could map some
traffic to a static content service that
is serving static web pages that have
been pre generated you can map other
parts of your URL paths to dynamic
content you know if you need to talk to
a database and all this can be expressed
within an object that is then
declaratively applied to your cluster
and then instantiated in terms of a
Google cloud l7 load balancer with that
we're going to switch over and do a
quick demo excellent
so for this demo I've pre provisioned
two clusters in two different regions so
there's one cluster that's in the US
West one region and one cluster that's
in the Europe West one region and what
I'm going to show you is how easy it is
to deploy an application onto Google
container engine and get it up and
running and serving real traffic to
end-users so the first thing that we are
going to do is this application is going
to use cloud spanner which is a newly
announced part of Google compute engine
and cloud spanner is a global database
that has strong support for transactions
it turns out to talk to cloud spanner
the identity model requires you to use a
service account so we're going to do is
we're going to create something called a
secret in kubernetes that encapsulates
the client-side credentials of that
service account to allow us access to
cloud spanner now haven't mentioned
secrets yet but what secrets do is
secrets decouple the sort of sensitive
information of your application such as
passwords or private keys from the
actual configuration of your application
and this is great
because the configuration of application
you generally want to put in source
control especially if you're running a
production because that makes it easier
for you to version and to share among
multiple people but you really don't
want to check your passwords into source
control
I know we've probably all seen you know
people will do a search of github and
find all sorts of passwords on github
images which is not really a best
practice so secrets allow you to
separate those two pieces of data so the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to create a deployment deployment
is a higher-level controller that
creates pods for you generally you don't
want to create pods by yourself because
a pod has a limited lifetime if a pod
dies it will not be recreated but if you
create a higher level controller like a
deployment the deployment is then
responsible for making sure that the pot
is always running so in this case we've
created a deployment with a single
replica which is going to launch a
single pod for us and in the deployment
specification there are lots of
different fields most of them are not
actually very important this one's
pretty important this tells us which
container we're actually going to run
this deployment has a single container
and then this container is parameterised
by a few environment variables so
through the environment we're going to
tell it where to connect to like which
which spanner database instance we're
going to connect to and then we're also
going to tell it where to get the
credentials to connect to that database
so we just created a secret that secret
is automatically mounted by kubernetes
inside of the pod at this location and
then the code will read the seeker from
that location and connect and connect to
spanner caps lock there we go so if we
then look at our pods in the cluster
we'll see that we have a single pod and
it's now in the running state so while
we were inspecting the mo file the
scheduler took that deployment turn it
into pods found a place to run the pod
and the system then fetch that container
image from Google container registry
instantiate it and now it's running so
that's great
so next what we're going to do is we're
going to create a service so in this
case the service that we're creating is
a service with an external load balancer
what this external load balancer will do
as I explained before is it will
actually talk to the Google cloud API s
and create a load balancer for you that
will expose your service to the Internet
if you leave if you leave this last line
off you will create a service that is
only accessible inside of your cluster
if we list services you can see that the
kubernetes service is the default
service it's provided with your cluster
and the service we just created is
called next the external IP takes about
a minute or so to show up and once that
IP shows up we'll be able to go ahead
and look at that service in the web
browser and see and load our web page so
while we're waiting for that we will go
back and look at our networking tab in
the cloud console and if we look at load
balancing we should see here's our
service so our service is now being
provisioned by the system so this is
done automatically for you you tell
kubernetes i'd like a service
externalized it goes ahead and programs
that for you and there it goes so now we
have an external IP address so go ahead
and load that aha there we go great so
our plot is serving a simple web page
tells us the name of the pod so we can
actually go back and verify gee t125
great looks like it's matched up and
it's telling us the region that it's
running in now our pod is pretty simple
it serves this data but it also writes
an event into spanner and so if we go
into the cloud console we can actually
load up spanner and we can find the
database that we provisioned and we can
actually search in the database and say
ok look we've got requests they're all
coming in to us West one ok that's great
so we've got our service it's been
pushed into one cluster
it's externally exposed if you guys want
you can get to same IP address and
you'll get the same response back each
of those responses is now being written
to spanner so one of those powerful
things about kubernetes is the way we've
deployed this application it's very easy
but it's also very easy to do it again
and again and again and so in this
example we have two clusters in two
different regions of the world and we
can apply exactly the same yellow files
to our second cluster and get exactly
the same results we can get the same
code running and it's since it's been
parameterised it will now tell us that
it's running in Europe so to do this
what we're going to do is we're going to
switch contexts so the kubernetes client
command-line interface knows how to talk
to a single cluster but it has
credentials to talk to multiple clusters
and using contexts you can actually
switch between different clusters that
are all been configured you can actually
you can pass it on the command line for
each command you run or in this case
we're going to sort of set the global
context so we don't have to pass it for
each of the commands the three commands
I'm I'm copying now are exactly the
three commands they were previously run
they're just running them now in a
different environment so again if we get
deployments we see that there's the same
name of the deployment if we actually
list the nodes in our cluster we can now
see that we are we are indeed talking to
the Europe cluster and we're no longer
talking to the US West cluster and if we
try to get services again we'll see that
it's pending if we run a query here
again so all of our access just like we
had a couple that went to Europe West
that's probably from when I was testing
prior to the presentation I forgot to
clear out the database that's still
pending so we give that just a second to
come up we can check on our load
balancer again and watch watch it get
created here so on this page we've got
the single load balancer that was there
before and shortly we will get a second
load balancer okay there it's coming up
so quite shortly here we should have
another IP address and there it is
excellent
and when we load this IP address instead
of saying us west one it should tell us
now we're running in Europe and again
it's telling us the name of the pod that
is hosting us application so we can if
we want scale our replicas out and we
can see the pod name change so now we
see that we have we've requested there
to be two replicas and if we reload the
page we should see it flip between the
two may take a second for that to show
up so now we have our service it's been
deployed into two different regions
which is great we can serve European
customers from Europe we can serve US
customers from the US if we'd like by
pointing them to two different IP
addresses which we can map to domain
names but most people want to have sort
of a single entry point for all of their
customers and one easy way to do that is
you create a DNS entry and you can put
both of these IP addresses in the DNS
entry that will cause traffic to
round-robin between the two clusters
which is perfectly reasonable but we
think a much better solution is to use
Google's a global cloud l7 load balancer
the l7 load balancer will automatically
push traffic to the two clusters based
on where the request is coming from so
for this demo I've pre provisioned an l7
load balancer you can see it's
configured to point to the two clusters
one in Europe West one and one in u.s.
West one and you can actually see that
in both cases all of the backends are
healthy so the backends here are the the
VMS the nodes that are part of the
cluster and then if we go look at the
traffic you can see that it turns out
we're sending traffic to both of these
backends so before the presentation
started I started a while loop I should
do it more slowly with a curl command so
I've set up a DNS entry that points to
my l7 IP address and just you know ten
times a second I'm curling curling that
from my laptop now my laptops on the
west coast of the US and so the majority
of the responses here are going
to be uswest one if you watch watch this
line as it toggles but I set the l7 load
balancer so that after getting five
requests per second to the US it'll
actually spill over traffic to Europe so
what this means is that if too many
requests are coming in that will
overload my set of backends they'll
spill over to the second cluster and you
can see from the terminal output here
that every once in a while we are
getting responses that are spilling over
to Europe likewise if we load the l7 IP
address here for the most part we will
get us West but every once in a while
we'll get Europe because of traffic
spilling over so this was great so now
we've deployed our application we deploy
it in multiple regions we're serving
traffic globally what happens if
something goes wrong so in this case
we've got requests coming right in from
both places and we're going to so we're
gonna switch back to the US West cluster
by changing our context and we're going
to delete our service so this is
simulating what happens if something's
wrong now your service no longer resists
your service is no longer exposed to the
Internet if you go to the first IP
address they was trying to serve us West
one it's not going to work anymore right
so that service IP address was gone so
if you've set up DNS you'd have two IP
addresses that were being round-robin
and about half the time your customers
would stop getting responses and even
worse with DNS propagation delays if you
want to change the DNS entry it's going
to take quite a while before that change
gets out to all of your customers and
they actually see the new IP address
that they should be going to it's in
Europe but if we look at the l7 balancer
it has automatically failed all of our
traffic over to the cluster that is
healthy and all the responses now are
coming from Europe and you can see now
that they're bouncing back and forth
between the two different pods that
we've scaled up to and there's a little
bit of lag in the cloud console but if
we refresh this in a second we'll see
that all of the traffic is now
overflowing and it does mark here that
all of our backends are unhealthy
and with that I think we're gonna switch
back to the slides so the final area
that I'm talking about today is
portability as I mentioned earlier we
recognize that not everyone has a luxury
of running their application in Google's
cloud one of the primary tenants of
kubernetes is that we should have
portability across deployment
environments you know kubernetes should
run great in Google's cloud it should
run great on premise it you're under
gate on different operating systems and
different hardware architectures you
know anywhere you can run containers you
should be able to run kubernetes to
manage those containers for you now it's
really easy for someone to sign up on
stage and tell you you know these these
platitudes about how easy it should be
to run here it is anywhere but but what
we want to do is sort of show you
through examples of customers and so
pokey is a company who decided to
rebuild their monolithic application
using micro services and containers and
they chose to use cuber Nettie's for
their container centric infrastructure
you know they launched kubernetes in
their existing environment they ran it
themselves for a little while and then
they decided you know it's it's a lot of
work to keep up with updates it's a lot
of work to manage my own cluster we're
gonna try out Google container engine
and so they switch to go container
engine now we have a happy customer but
in the process of migrating into Google
container engine because all of their
applications were written to run on
kubernetes it gave them the confidence
that if they do want to run anywhere
else as long as they can run kubernetes
they are free to go wherever they'd like
so today you know they're a happy
customer but you know if they get
dissatisfied then they are free to run
it on GCE itself without using Google
Tanner engine or on bare metal or
anywhere else they'd like and the reason
that this works is because kubernetes
provides really good extensibility
points kubernetes can scale down all the
way to running on your laptop if you
want to run a development environment
again we would not recommend that for
production but it's great for testing
out your applications before you push
them to production it means you can run
your containers while you're on an
airplane without having access to the
Internet you can also run it on bare
metal you can run it in many different
cloud environments and the API
implementation of kubernetes is
completely open the whole system is
modular and you can replace different
components and the way that we support
different clouds
that we do the place different so
earlier in the presentation and in the
demo we showed how we can integrate with
Google's networking Google's cloud load
balancer Google's l7 load balancer all
of those when you're integrating with
those systems you were expressing the
intent of your application through
kubernetes objects through services and
through ingress objects and on gke are
on Google thinner engine we then
instantiate those objects through
Google's API s but if you're running
elsewhere you can run a different
ingress controller that might
instantiate your l7 load balancer using
nginx or you might instantiate it
service control are just using IP tables
so the whole system is modular and
replaceable and can run anywhere and the
other nice thing about this is your
applications are not written to depend
on any particular infrastructure your
applications depend upon the Kuban adsap
is and Kure Nettie's mediates those API
s with the environment that they're
running in so we've talked about the
network models another good example of
this is volumes so if you're running on
Google's cloud if you're most likely
using Google's PD's Google's persistent
disks which can be mounted into your
containers but if you're running on bare
metal you might instead have persistent
volumes that are backed by NFS and this
allows you to migrate easily migrate
your application from the legacy
deployments into containers and lift and
shift onto the cloud when you're ready
to migrate it further means that after
that migration as we saw with pokey that
you don't feel stuck where you went to
that you still have the flexibility to
go wherever you think is the best place
for your company so we like to say this
puts your apps on wheels and lets you
roll it around wherever you'd like to go
and with that I'm gonna hand it back to
him
Thank You Albert so we've seen that
production changes everything right and
we talked through some of customer
example how we in Google can help and I
forgot to mention maybe it's a nice
story to tell now about Niantic right
they they started on kubernetes 1.3 and
they had a different specific size of
cluster and need to scale it up on the
same time we were able to we were
releasing a new version of kubernetes
was that was supporting mm no VMs per
cluster
so without disturbing anything and for
us doing all the work for that we were
able to scale them out to a bigger class
so we first upgraded a cluster the
control plane and then the nodes and
they were able to grow to the scale they
needed and we saw auto scaling a we
talked about access control a load
balancing and of course portable to
portability we want to believe that you
have a choice and we want to keep you
that choice and have the freedom to make
a decision will commit to be the best
okay and this is our goal and to make
sure that this is the best place for you
to run your containerized applications
hey but all I speak about is about today
right and again as I said when we are
making a decision about where to run our
production workloads we want to make
sure that we can be confident that this
is the right platform when the right
decision for us for the future I really
like this quote from Sam because it's
able to capture in this in one quote
both the today and the future and the
first thing he mentioned is about a
kubernetes right and why kubernetes is
production-ready today and the future I
think one thing to note is about the
community the community has been growing
growing very fast it's one of the top
ten projects in github and from
engagement and looking on the 1,500
contributors and I think more
interesting even to say that all of
those 43 43,000 commits more than 50% of
them are actually not done by Googlers
this means that the pace of innovation
is mind-blowing okay the new features
the new requirements are really there to
make sure that every where you take
kubernetes and run your containers you
will have a production ready system I
also believe that this is really raises
the bar right when we speak about when
to release a new version of kubernetes
we look at all environments right and we
are making sure that it works well
everywhere and we have users and
contributors that are doing the same
what do you say for example if you're
planning to grow and you want to now
have a higher new professional people to
manage your cluster when you choose
Google container engine it's the same as
any other kubernetes deployment from
that knowledge
effective so having 200 meetups and
around the world allows you to hire
those professional to join the team
without the need to hire to train them
specifically to your system and the last
thing is that having that total arity by
having different projects based on
kubernetes you can change your
monitoring solution it talks about a lot
about the infrastructure but also the
tooling around around it your DevOps
tool chain your logging your monitoring
tracing all those those things can be
changed with new things that will come
along so to summarize Google container
engine benefit is first of all pure
upstream kubernetes this is the fastest
way to get the kubernetes releases
available to you in a reliable manner we
bring our 12 years of experience of
managing production systems on
containers to you by managing and
upgrading your cluster your control plan
and your VMs and you get all the
benefits and all the goodness of the
Google cloud platform you can really
focus on your application deployment hey
thank you very much
[Music]
you